[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
علينا
باشا
باشا باشا
حبيبي ماله ماله
يا طه
[موسيقى]
يا
لهوي شافني
الناس بقلبي في
[موسيقى]
ايديك
من كلام الناس
على راحتك خالص
وبراحتك خالص
[موسيقى]
الدلع دلع
يا عسل يا عسل يا عسل يا لالا
يا لالا
[موسيقى]
علموني يا لموني الوا نن عيوني لاموني يا
لموني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مفيش صاحبي
مفيش راجل
بقى راجل
بتعام
متكاملين ما في صاحبي
صاحبي مفيش راجل بقى راجل
متعامل ويتعب
[موسيقى]
صاحبي صاحي مفيش راجل يتعامل
الله سلاحك متكامل زمن عادي
[موسيقى]
يا حنفيه
معلش
[موسيقى]
مش قادر
يسمعك لكن
مش كل الكلام
اشاره
نتعلمهم يفهم
مني
بحبك
ودي ربينا معك وانا هساعدك مش قادر
يسمعك لكن مش كل الكلام بصوت لما تكون في
الغربه وتايه مش فاهم بيقولوا ايه
وتلاقي اللي بيفهم لغتك شف
[موسيقى]
وانا هساعدك مش قادرين
يسمعك لكن مش كل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قضيه الثوم مضاعف السمع والوشم في مصر
[موسيقى]
يا ابو العيون السود
لا لا لا
كيفك تملي عيد يا لالالي لا لا لا
[موسيقى]
الورد
قال العنب افتحوا
[موسيقى]
يا صاح حنان اسمر وكل قلبك يحبوني
لا لا لا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يا ليلي يا ليلي يا ليلي يا ليل
[موسيقى]
من حبي من حبي من حبي
تك يا
[موسيقى]
من حبي من حالي من ورا
وخبي الشوق
[موسيقى]
الجيران انت تك دوم تك دوم تك
دوم دوم دوم
[موسيقى]
لما تصادف
يا سلام والدنيا تدور كمان ان كنت انا
رايحه معرف ان كنت انا جايه
[موسيقى]
اه
واخبي الشوق واداري اداري
دوم دوم تك دوم
دوم تك دوم تك تك دوم دوم تك دوم تك تك
دوم دوم
تك دوم تك دوم دوم
[موسيقى]
ولا
يدا يا روح
[موسيقى]
الدنيا
بعطيك الحلوه حبايبي
واقول لك ايه يا جارينا
[موسيقى]
وناري
ا
[موسيقى]
لو الهوايه كنت اروح واوا
تك تك دومتك دوم دوم تك تك
من جوه يا غزالي واه يا غزالي
يا غزالي اه يا غزالي وقلبي خالي دوم سوا
[موسيقى]
ولا غاليه
والله يا ناسيني
[موسيقى]
امتى تجيني مجروح داويني يا ابو الهوى
دوم دوم دوم دوم دوم دوم دوم
يا
قلبي قلبي بيروح لعندك ويبوح بسرك وكل
اهاتي دوم دوم دوم دوم دوم دوم
دوم دوم دوم
[موسيقى]
كلها كلها
[تصفيق]
شاورما معموره بي
[موسيقى]
روت يا
بحبك موت هم هم هم هم هم هم هم هم هم هم
هم هم هم هم
وقله ماما الاكل
[موسيقى]
كلما
شبه المسكون
[موسيقى]
انت معموله في بيروت
يا
[موسيقى]
كلمني طمني
وارحمني
يوم يا
حبيبي
طالبك طالبك في نعمه
فين يا حبيبي
[موسيقى]
نار نار
يا حبيبي
[موسيقى]
تعب الهوى قلبي
والحلو مش داري
وان امتى
هنخبي على بعضي ونداري تعب الهوى تعب
الهوى تعب الهوى قلبي
حبيبي
وعليا لو في وسط
ما يبقاش عليا عليا ما ينفعش عليا
[موسيقى]
يا قلبي ولا تقوليش السكه منين
ده حبيبي معايا ما تسالنيش رايحين على فين
رايحين ههه
[موسيقى]
صوت شجيب اغنيه
اغنيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كيف الحال
خلف الجميع
فوق اللسان
لا
[موسيقى]
تزال
صوت شجيب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]